mais messieurs bonsoir on en avait
beaucoup beaucoup parlé en novembre
dernier lors de l'installation de cette
superbe poutre sous le pont champlain le
temps est maintenant venu de la retirer
ça va se passer d'ailleurs en fin de
semaine et de la remplacer par une
structure qui sera permanente et julie
bien sûr tout ça va occasionner la de
sérieux problèmes de circulation dans la
région de montréal est particulièrement
dans les secteurs au sud de voile à
plusieurs bretelles de sortie ou
d'entrer dans ce secteur du pont
champlain dans le secteur de l'île des
soeurs également qui seront donc fermés
il ya une bonne nouvelle c'est tombé en
fin d'après midi on nous annonçait qu'il
ya deux voies sur le pont victoria qui
seront par ailleurs ouvert en direction
sud après le match de hockey parce qu'il
rend probablement plusieurs personnes
sur l'île de montréal donc entre 15h et
18h alors pourquoi tout se casse tête
c'est parce qu'effectivement on
s'apprête à clore le chapitre de la
fameuse super coûterait
elles entravent la voix depuis plus de
six mois l'heure est maintenant arrivé
de retirer la super poutre enfin à vont
partir
cette poutre de 75 tonnes a été installé
d'urgence en novembre dernier on venait
de découvrir une fissures inquiétantes
dans la structure il faut maintenant
protéger les automobilistes de façon
permanente ce sera à l'aide d'un
treillis d'acier que ces travailleurs
s'affairent à installer à l'aide d'une
barre ch qui prend plus de temps être
installés donc c'est pourquoi on on a on
l'utilisé vraiment comme deuxième étape
est également qui peut difficilement
s'installer en conditions hivernales et
en novembre dernier l'a vraiment ce à
des conditions climatiques très dures
alors ça a été beaucoup plus difficile
d'intervenir par en dessous
mais qui dit travaux dit chantier et
détours routier d'autant plus qu'on
profite de l'installation du tri pour
procéder au pavage de l'autoroute 15
plusieurs bretelles d'entrée et de
sortie seront fermés vers la rive sud
par exemple la sortie 53 sera fermée une
seule voie sera ouverte dans cette
direction vers la rive nord la sortie 61
vers atwater sera impraticable et de
voie sera ouverte en direction de
montréal bref éviter autant que possible
le pont champlain la circulation sera
également plus difficile sur l'île des
soeurs les automobilistes cyclistes à
leurs heures espère simplement que le
treillis sera sécuritaire mais le
montant qu'elle soit loeb pensons
sécurité qu'ils enlèvent que ce soit pas
tous complètement réparé près pour les
travaux qui s'en viennent par ailleurs
prête pour les travaux d'un petit peu
inquiet notre voie cyclable ici
des travaux pénibles pour les
automobilistes mais qui permettront
enfin au pont champlain est de retrouver
sa pleine capacité et de dire adieu à la
super pole ici julie marceau radio
canada montréal